have you noticed that putting gambit in
your youtube title increases views by
like 20
yeah which is it's incentivizing me to
play more
tricky and maybe dubious gambits
okay so format i have to win 10 in a row
uh
andrea and alexandra team up on me uh
it's 5.0
uh blitz chess let's send a challenge
and oh and i'll be playing as many
tricky dubious aggressive openings
as possible
things look and sound okay i hope
okay challenge has been sent
let's do this yeah i highly encourage
people
to watch both streams if this goes on
youtube the link will be in the
description
to their side of this debacle
so much suspense this rotating
magnifying glass gives me
some anxiety should probably avoid
looking at it
yeah should maybe i should i have their
stream open people can just tell me what
what's happening if if they're having
any oh okay it's starting
um ooh sicilian time let's play a smith
mora
okay this is the first tricky aggressive
gambit
i saw she plays maybe oh she does play
g6
let's play h4 i'm going kind of bananas
here
but i want to play h5 i should have
prepared this
because i knew she played g6 i was more
preparing the main line
when uh when whites or when black takes
can take with queen man i'm nervous i
don't know why i'm
nervous here like there's a b5
because every game is crucial like i
can't lose a single game
[Music]
so the idea is to put the bishop here
put the queen here and not blunder upon
but maybe sack upon
every blunder is a sacrifice if you have
the right perspective on
life okay let's play bishop g5
yeah because there's there's no knight
move that defends the bishop
now i can take
conceding the bishop pair there's also
queen a4 which is kind of interesting
24 92 etc
let's have some fun
so i keep the pawn defended a6 isn't
really a threat because the thing is
pinned
or the the pawn would be pinned to the
rook
time is very important play knight d2
here
thanks for subbing i should probably
move the box some
somewhere less annoying
maybe night here and there's not a 3
2 i kind of want to preserve pawn f3
yeah and this way i have bishop f4 to
the queen
um
it's not a threat yet but it's about to
be a threat
good castle
i don't think the queen's getting
trapped
okay stay focused rook b8 may be
expected
d6 is very solid
play bishop c4 maybe
i have a bad feeling about this position
already
i could take
okay let's take not the best opening i
guess
i can see that the bishop hair i'm
strengthening black center
but at least it's playable i'm debating
whether to take with queen
uh which is probably a very fine move
i'll play queen c2 i'm keeping queens on
the board
it's a question how black wants to
develop the bishop some idea of knight
d4
yeah let's splits out knight d4 probably
f3 coming
so yeah they played the opening very
well here
my box position is very solid and b5 is
coming i could play a4 but then still b5
but maybe it makes sense like takes in
queen b3
let's do it maybe i'll get the pawn to
a5
create some weak square i'm down on time
man
okay time is pretty level
ah i forgot to open my coffee i'll open
the coffee after the the next game
maybe i'll play a5
the king probably wants to be here like
whenever this diagonals open
kings just a bit more comfortable
comfortable
on each one it rookie it's a fine move
let's put the king on h1
some idea of f5 f4 the only drawback
or f f4 f5 only drawback is knight g4
create a weak square
i feel like the knight is better on e3
oh the bishop might be nice on b6
just trying to figure out where the
pieces are happiest
because this knight is not doing too
much
ooh so d5 might be coming
this is not a typical like dragon type
move
but it's playable
i can't really exploit the d5 square yet
but okay pawn d5 i can take and win the
pawn
oh but h4 is hanging
it was very devious
i mean i might as well kind of commit
myself
c4 they're playing a very good game so
far
only slight time advantage i want to
play c5
and b4 first
idea c5 d6 get some majestic pawns
bishop f6 isn't quite threatening this
because i take
e4 could be slightly annoying like black
has a bishop here so i'm scared of the
position opening up
the e4 is very risky too for black so
diagonal opens
i still want to go for this stuff
a very bold decision
it might be a good decision
[Music]
maybe take
it's not entirely clear what to do here
actually
maybe just c4 immediately
see four takes takes
okay i'm making a calculated risk
takes like take and counter-attack the
bishop there's a line
takes takes i hit the rook there's no
queen g3 because my queen defends g3
i think it's okay
one drawback is takes takes i can't play
d6 because it takes and the
thing is pinned my knight wouldn't be
defended
but as long as i'm up on time that could
be the
determining factor
oh okay so now maybe d6
and what else to play i cut the queen
and my my queen's defended which is nice
so there's no
okay that's a fine move
okay what to do my knight's still
attacked
let's play this and then rook d1 bishop
f6 expected
i like my pawns at least oh i did i
blunder queen d6
it's complicated takes takes takes takes
takes d7
and might be saved
let's remove that yeah the prompt
the pawn promotion in the end well i
want to sack a queen maybe
could sack a queen maybe oh let's take
here
queen h4 shouldn't hurt me
i just want to simplify into an endgame
where i can promote
i have to avoid any perpetual too okay
let's take that
oh let's not hang a pawn okay there's no
checks
okay i think life is good
it's a very tense game though it's not
plunder
keep everything defended now let's start
pushing the pawns
it's a cool breakthrough i'm attacking
two pawns so you get c6
eventually c7
oh they want to perpet me
but you're not preparing me
check check
wait let's be careful let's be civil i
have to be calling the son of time
too man this king
is so active oh they want to get
stalemated
but no stalemates okay because pawns can
move and the king could move too
wow that was stressful that was only the
first game
man they played really well like the
opening and then the middle game
and then even like time wise we were
pretty level throughout
okay so
one down eric i've been missing your
stream oh i missed you too
how's it going good to catch you stream
man raising hand man raising hand
thanks man okay
chameleon cold brew and my palms are
sweating so it's like
years of tea and chest wait very good
lovely soon i will have the big z
rebel haha i'm frozen face oh this is
really good
mexican coffee oh thanks so much
unlimited rice pudding
okay um am i expecting a london i don't
know what i'm expecting
oh ah this is like an anti-gambit
opening
let's play let's play whatever this is
it's kind of like a
mexican wait
what is this can i gambit here
i don't know if i can gambit here i
could play weird chess let's play
d6 and then maybe eventually e5
oh thanks for the coffee win bits i
appreciate that i'll play h6 h6 g5
this won't be a gambit but it'll be
it'll be dynamic and offbeat and
aggressive
you can get some g5 emotes oh thanks so
much
meridian matters
okay so i got the fiancado
i would imagine andrea is like choosing
the opening
i'm playing very solidly i'm building
the illuminati
i could castle could play g
oh let's play g4 it's in the style of
that's in the spirit of the style of
this whatever
this opening is i could take with knight
maybe too
at the bishop but probably better to
develop
the the one undeveloped piece queen d7
okay so maybe i'll castle queenside
i think i've successfully kind of
disturbed the london
i don't know how successful it is yet
you play rook g8
i mean the rook is kind of obstructed by
the bishops but in the future
maybe this pawn could be a target it's
undefended
let's play a5
very crab like
now attacking the pawn yeah a good move
okay let's dance around with the knight
this knight needs to find a purpose in
life maybe e697
yeah i really thought like the fact that
they're teaming up would slow them down
but they're playing really quickly which
kind of concerns me
another concerning thing these pawns are
menacing you see five may be coming
i don't have so much space but this is
this is hippo like or hedgehog like
or maybe a combination of a hippo and a
hedgehog
play bishop f5
actually not sure what else to do here
c5 is probably coming
play rook t8
like we're kind of just waiting for each
other to do something
like who will strike first
to close my tabs
[Music]
okay tabs are closed
okay i'm up on time somehow
sometimes the best strategy in blitz is
just to give your opponents
or give your opponent options in this
case opponents
just so they're um like if they're
indecisive they'll spend more time okay
now i have a
potential even though it's covered
[Music]
i think if i can play e5 maybe d5
play queen e7 first
it was really a game of cat and mouse
and hippo
but okay e5 e5 is now preparing
whoa it's money it's 777. i love your
content
i love you too from germany thanks so
much appreciate that
see if i was a really strong move
i'm scared king f8
by e5 maybe still
i could play d5 too
d5 is kind of ugly but okay no offense
to d5
this i play this i'm banking on the fact
that i'll get knight f4 and maybe bishop
f5 and
life will be okay
white's grabbing so much space here
it's like this face odyssey wait
leave the cap off
is unexpected cinnamon in this more
coming
um i think so much
oh how do you do the
okay i have to take that otherwise my
queen is kind of stuck
rook takes expected
huh i want to do tactics but they don't
work
oh it's money bhagavan hamari madata
karam
amen amen was that japanese
what language is that or korean or thai
maybe it's thai thanks so much
yeah that's a nice solid move i always
play bishop f8
man the position's so sad mike's
actually really solid here too
that's a good move i have to do this
this is undesirable but i'm opening a c
file
i'm actually in trouble here kind of
like really in trouble
i'm gonna have to resort to tricks maybe
like i'm losing my pawns
thanks for that
no this is really bad
okay let's focus
first step is not to lose a queen
second step is to create tricks
there's definitely some tricks in the
position like this and then bishop b4 is
a threat
so rook seat i think would be a blunder
[Music]
roxy 7 good move have some check
check i guess there's bishop d1
let's try this oh there's definitely
counter play
i'm gonna need to get lucky somehow
the pawns attacked down a little bit of
time
[Music]
oh the rook's hanging too
unexpected gift i don't think i care
about it though
let's play this threatening this because
both pieces are pinned
this is really risky
what oh no
oh that was a really good move
please play queen e7 please gambit
i see it i'm almost mated but i'm not
quite nated
this is really intense
queen f7 but then i can take
can maybe take everything there i don't
know
[Music]
i'm so scared
when f7 rook g7 might survive
i have to be careful because there's
mating ideas
oh no i can take okay this is safer i
can take and then take
oh play this move first
check king is running
what was this game
hey it's a fork i like forks
wow
oh man
okay
now it's white's king getting hunted
man they were really fast from the end
there too was that game
man these games
i have to be really careful it was nice
to hear them scream in the other tab
that's fun making people scream but i
was about to scream too
like it was so close to me there were so
many different like checking
so many different checks but i didn't
see the meat for whites
yeah i'm not sure if there's a clear win
here i imagine there is
but okay rematch
that's only two games i feel like i just
ran a marathon
or at least like a sprint oh man i keep
freezing to take off the cap
thanks for subbing everyone thank you
aika
and mordech cat and anton zero
i know i know it's stressful and
stressful because it's one game and it's
over
i know i know i was almost over there
it's like having a near-death experience
it's going to make me appreciate the
next like just being alive in this match
i could play tricky london stuff um
let's play e4 i'll play london later
maybe
um let's play the slime knight c3 okay
i'm gonna play um
not quite a gambit but it's a tricky
variation
um oh it's actually similar to the first
game
but this is a better version because
there's no knight g4
the first game black had we had the h4h5
included
um
okay so yeah not a gambit but
kind of a tricky aggressive opening uh
i'll develop i just want to recover from
these first two games
i feel like they they definitely played
stronger as a team
[Music]
uh what to play here actually i think
we're following some main line
bishop g5 looks interesting
i'm fully developed the light had to
undevelop
but black has a bishop hair arguably i'm
overextended
there's some pressure against my queen
there's some cool ideas of knight e4 to
d6 because the pawn is pinned
ooh pawn d6 immediately
interesting
i could queenside castle
like a boss
so basically okay controlling the d file
does not have the battery
i'm also freeing the e1 square for the
rook
let's move back i was thinking there was
some knight h6 to f5 idea
but now it's no more with a pawn here
i really want to take and exploit this
pin
but the problem is this is pinned so
many pins in this position
oh this pawn is pinned too to the the
queen
i wonder if i get away with this
i would lose a bishop in the end but win
some pawns
hmm
d5 interesting move
so the drawback of d5 is now that
there's no more there's no more pressure
at least on the center and i have the c5
square maybe
it's 94.2 but then queen a5
hmm i really want to play queen a4
but then bishop d7
maybe i can start with it because i'm
preventing queen a5
just trying to limit active play
z5 is coming
wondering if i can get away with this
this and then this
it gets a bit weird i play e6 2 maybe
oh e6 do i dare
it's kind of a cool gambit looking move
i'm gonna start with rookie one might as
well prepare the
pawn push into the side of queen a3
probably
yeah like c5 point a3 then both pawns
are attacked
and queen b6 is a respectable move maybe
still queen a3
that way i cover b2 i'm also exerting
pressure against e7
and i'm also freeing the square for the
knight to come to c5 and also a4 to
attack the queen
yeah so queen coin a3 was very
multi-purpose
oh there's a lot of pressure against b2
and queen b4 may be coming
yeah i'm down on time i thought i had
like good opening preparation but
and they're still playing quickly
yeah i have to trade queens not what i
wanted
but knight c5 i got my outpost
so my knight defends the bishop we might
see this threatening to take and then
win a piece
yeah very tricky so i'll play bishop g3
okay positional endgame time
black is probably doing fine here i
guess i'll play c3
c3 b4 then a4
yeah i hear a4 and then i can take and
win a pawn and then
the knight is actually quite stable here
unless black plays bishop f8
um
i have to deal with it if it happens but
thankfully there's no
oh there's a cool idea rook 8 knight b7
to d6
oh but i don't have knight knight b7
here i have knight a6
if rook 8 i fork
that's risky oh i'm along bishop a3
bishop a3 king c2
rook b2 king d3
and then c5
knight c7 here there's some lines where
i'm close for promoting but i'm not sure
at least i'm up on time okay bishop a3
was maybe a slight miss
but rook a7 is coming ooh
my rook rook d4 but then c5
i'm playing c2 yeah rook b7 was actually
a fine move
because this is coming and i might lose
both a pawns
my babies okay maybe i win c6 so it's
just a fair trade
interesting let's wait for the b
file i'm kind of inducing this
but i do have knight b8 oh i have a cool
idea knight b8
but there's king c7 it might work though
let's try a knight b8 and then a6
it's very unusual idea but if rook a
i've rook here
my knight is almost trapped but not
quite
i want to do this as soon as possible
oh my knight might get trapped
ah oh no i can defend it i can double up
i'm just in time to double up i think
and then rook b7 will still be a threat
these games are so stressful
this is such a weird position it was
night such an mvp
like doing things from the b8 square
yeah that was an issue for i guess like
the king's fight for black was a bit
undeveloped
so i had time to to get the pieces in
play
to rescue the night maybe
and it's very hard to stop this idea too
like rook b7 coming
and if knight f5 i play this and i'll
eventually win the c6 pawn
and or promote the a pawn
okay i i i don't think we're gonna see
like an intense time scramble
hopefully but you never know can't let
my guard down what does this move
oh the bailout oh but not quite bailing
out
okay
they actually they really diffuse the
opening well
i thought like i kind of felt like the
opening was gonna be
a nice like crush but
i don't know maybe i missed some
opportunity i mean some
just kind of solid moves from black
and then yeah things got really weird
around here
with the whole queen side shenanigans
but yeah no mercy deep breath
let's do this oh
am i on their stream shout out to botez
live
hi people how's it going
i'm not that technologically advanced to
have them in like a stream window
but i encourage people to just
have a tab open or have squad stream
maybe
i hope oh they can't hear me okay that's
good but they can see my wave right
okay rematch
okay rematch let them take a break if
they want to
oh oh squad can't have both sounds
but okay probably more people will be
watching in the future
on youtube where then you can probably
watch both at once hopefully anyway okay
what to play let's play d5
maybe i'll play uh i can't play lucini
i could play the opposite of lukini
which is
like a whatever queen scam it yeah
i'm gambling this pawn please take it
they're not taking it nice game are
there any
gambits here i know andrea's like
actually
pretty well prepared oh there is a
gambit
there's a cool line okay let's start
with this she's going to play 92.
almost a full year hi eric glad to see
you streaming
oh it's brian welcome back ryan thanks
for subbing
for almost a full year um
man i want to play gambit but
can i play a gambit in this line there's
an almost gambit
let's yeah let's take and play bishop f5
there's a gambit line with queen b3
um or knight d2 first and then
eventually gambling b7
but i don't think we're going to get
into it unfortunately
but maybe okay
the queen can't come to b3 now because
that would lose a bishop
actually the knight can't come to d2 so
we might just
have a normal game of chess
i guess
[Music]
hey it's straw favi or straw fay
i can't read thanks for subbing
appreciate that
ooh
i'm tempted to take with the bishop in
97 but i'm not sure
i could go after the pawn let's do it it
feels like a lot of the games i'm
conceding the bishop hair
like a lot of the games they're they're
having the two bishop advantage
which hasn't been like my master
strategy
but okay i have some positional play
against the pawn which is a little bit
overextended there's no f4
the problem is i don't know if i'm
threatening to take it
there's a potential pin but maybe i can
torture it some more
rook h5 let's do it
i'm just going to attack with everything
i have maybe
f6 f6 might be too much though
thanks for subbing tby gems
713. appreciate that
yeah this is a slightly exotic maneuver
so i'm not i'm no longer cast in
kingside but i could fake castle
or manual castle
some i was about to say some g5 idea
that would plunder a rook
let's uh not allow the knight to come
here
oh c4 is a good move thanks for the bits
j cheeto play this move
it's a pass pawn
there's knight c2 let's do it looks fun
rook d8 knight c5 maybe
now it's in balance because we both have
like potential weaknesses
i don't think i'm going to take this
pawn anytime soon the the pin would be
too uncomfortable
um and then in the meantime i'm trying
to
have some support for this pawn yeah
knight c5
ooh threatening d3
potential fork so with b4 i just ignore
it and play d3
i think
i keep forgetting to take off the cap
and i don't want to leave it uncapped
because then there's more spill
potential
hmm so it's a question how hot
white actually stops d3 maybe knight a1
that would be sad
i think queen f3 most expected
but maybe then i can take not sure
even queen f3 rook f5 but then g4
knight a1 ah i kind of predicted it
right
does that make me a profit
can i play d3 here
hmm that's such a funny move i just want
to laugh at this move
but okay let's um let's not waste time
i mean rook f5 is neat
d3 is also kind of cool i could play d3
and knight d4
i think this knight b3 may be coming
that's a weird position
i think what i'll do i'll play this move
just stopping any this uh b4 move and
then
i'll just try and solidify
i think this is a civil approach
maybe yeah because now i have a defended
pass pawn
i mean white kind of solve the problem
of the depressing knight
so we're both kind of solid here f4
probably coming
i'm gonna try and use a b file
put the queen on b7 and then i can hop
[Music]
around
some e4 ideas maybe
oh g4 may be coming
oh no i'm getting forked ah they're not
falling for it ah
let's reverse mong cloud reverse to lane
bomb clown
ah i'm still getting forked
please fork me please
they see my idea if g4 is gonna force me
with rook h3
okay do i have any tricks i probably
should not allow g4
hm i could still let's still go for this
i'm still long g4 so now the idea is
knight h4 threading mate
okay so i i kind of induced g4 so i'm
threatening made in one
if rook g1 i probably have to just move
back
and then it's a weird position
not sure what to make of it it's also
probably a good move
oh but i have
nah knight f3 doesn't quite work
that's unfortunate
another 5 could be an idea oh
does it quite ah it almost works let's
play that at 5.
whoa it's a raid it's a benefiting gold
grain i think spend ben feingold
if you're just joining i'm playing the
botest sisters
in a match it's an adoption match i've
won
three very hard fought intense
sweat inducing games this is game four
i'm throwing made in two
uh let's take this oh
i'm gonna win the queen i think
what's the best way to win the queen oh
this is yeah this is the best way
everything's falling thanks ben i'll
dedicate that wind to ben
reading at the right time the forks the
rook fork was real
shout out to ben was it a gambit i don't
know
it was something so there is a moment
man there's a moment in this game
when i played king e7 just to show
i was really hoping for g4 and i was
gonna take
and then say oh no my rook and then do
this and then it's
it's meaning um oh it's karen too shout
out to karen
really appreciate the raid hope you guys
had a good stream
[Music]
okay every game we take like a small
breather try and
calm the nerves drink some coffee
have some nice lightly sweetened
mexican coffee has some cinnamon to it
[Music]
okay man not even halfway there
okay let's rematch let's do this
i have to stretch
and these games are are hard fought
really have to be careful not to let my
guard down
like even this game i felt like i was
better and then they kind of solidified
like
this was a weird thing but it led to a
solid position
oh they have washroom break okay
which gives me a a stretching break or a
flexing break
i should lift more oh okay let's um
i'll play d4 mix it up i don't know what
they play against this
maybe i'll play a black mardemer
or oh i could play um what do they call
this a bronstein
the bronstein gabbat i have zero prep
but they probably don't have any prep
either
so hopefully we're on level terms even
though i'm down upon
it's kind of like an alakan if they move
back then like kick the knife around
it's also like soccer or football
uh let's play this move
i should yeah if i'm gonna play this i
should at the very least be prepared for
d5
um okay let's play h3 i might give away
the bishop here
i mean knight h6 expected
there's a cool idea it's a sack of
bishop i'm calculating knight h6
takes takes bishop here bishop d7 e6
isaac bishop and then queen h5
oh they sack a knight what wait they're
counter gamuting a knight okay i have to
take it
what is this
wow i'm so bold
but not as bold as my coffee don't mess
with a mexican coffee
so i'm i'm up a night for a pawn oh no
neg for two pawns
ah because they want f2 and my king is
kind of naked
but i have open files but they're gonna
have like a nice caro khan position
uh what to do i could play bishop d3
the thing is bishop d3 bishop e4 but
then knight c3
let's do it
all i want to do is trade get an end
game
and enjoy my material advantage
try and keep the time advantage too
god am i losing a pawn i forgot my d4
pawn is attacked twice
and the knight's pinned so d4 pawns
isn't even defended
but okay if takes i take here and i win
back the pawn
actually if takes takes takes i win d5
as well there's also bishop e5 ideas
so everything should be okay
just have to stay calm
it's nice having having an extra minor
piece
you can fight for more squares it's hard
for black to actually defend e4 again
maybe f5
f5 probably not
f5 i can take
now there's a few different candidate
moves i'm assuming there's going to be
some kind of capture
okay that's what i like to see
always happy with the trades oh that's a
solid move
i was looking forward to winning a pawn
okay so there's two attackers i probably
have to take
there's also there's bishop b5
i can take now i can put my king on g2
hopefully oh e5 is hanging
what oh because i took
i forgot e5 was hanging
so black has three pawns
for the piece now okay but still it
should still be okay
hopefully queen g3
there's targets
black and soul castle
hmm if i take i'm on the sack but
my sacking is no good
this is actually a scary position the
king is
really really just naked on g2
and lock's gonna castle and then build
up the center
so the question is what to do i use the
files to attack
or can i just trade somehow
trying to calculate bishop e3 takes
takes d4
takes takes probably no good
[Music]
i could just take i could take the night
because the night's gonna cause
problems later let's take the knight and
be solid hopefully
and this is really not an easy position
though it's easier for black to play i
think
so the pawns just start rolling but i'm
threatening a trick with knight e4 maybe
or maybe not
okay queen g3 i just have to stop e5
and keep my king safe
maybe rook f1 tricks threaten some
discoveries
ah c2's attacked
i'm thinking about just gamuting it like
yolo
i could play rook d2 as well
let's play rook t2
my position is getting scarier though
here brook f1
some idea bishop d6 maybe
i think we're both trying to attack on
the king side kind of
like i have the files but i also have
less shelter
okay i'm threatening this problem no
probably bishop d6
no but bishop d6 is takes
bishop b5 there's queen g6
interesting
so f6 is coming which is kind of
terrifying
i'm not sure if i can stop it
i play queen g4 not what i want to do
there's a cool idea just like king h1
rook g2
i think i'll go for just tuck the king
away
safe and sound threatening mate now
queen of seven yeah okay so we're both
being safe
i'm down on time though to protect my
time
okay let's build up pressure i need to
the knight wants to find a happier place
um i want a sack the sacking
sacking doesn't work i can play this
move
and shift the rook back if e5 i take it
oh i think this works
i'm down on time but it's close to so
level
let's be fancy takes takes
okay they're going to try and flag me
probably
i have an extra knight i won the crucial
e5 pawn threatening this amount to win
this pawn
oh then fork i like forks
okay can i relax
oh there's some tricky tricky like
rookie one
i mean let's still do this rookie one
should be okay
queen c3 probably
okay so threatening the king rook f8 i
have knight g4
my g4 probably coming regardless the
double discovery the double fossil
i'm also attacking the rook and the king
can't actually move away from
the diagonal and d4 only delays the pain
oh did the thing crash what just
happened
something was flashing i think it's okay
though
oh no my queen okay
that's a nice finish that's a nice
finish
that's a cool nate because the knight
controls g7
okay man something yeah trust.com was
like
flashing me for a moment not sure i'm
not sure what happened there but
i stayed connected internet was clutch
it was a cool game that was a
topsy-turvy roller coaster game
we're only halfway there man
okay focus deep breath coffee time
what is the chameleon opening oh let's
accept
[Music]
okay they're playing like a lunge in
every game
what to play trying to think
i play d i'm actually trying to think
what to play here
because knight f3 let's play this move
um maybe c i'll play c5 reverse queen's
gamut
trying to prevent a london because if
bishop here i just take it
we might see c3 unfortunately
a c3 could be a bummer oh e3
uh okay
this is new i'll i'll let them
take if they want
this is like a this is called kali
type thing oh they take oh
gambit accepted i actually don't know
what to
how i proceed here probably this move
and if c4 i play d4
that's a logical move
oh bishop here is coming
so we might get a structure bishop b5 e4
knight d4 bishop d7
i've seen the structure before if i get
the chance i want to win back the pawn
or do i probably do
okay so i gambled it but i won the pawn
back
so now it's peaceful wow it's a rain
it's another raid from anna chess
thanks so much anna chess also shout out
to nhs really appreciate it
you're reading in the middle of the
match if you're just joining
this is chess i'm playing botez live
uh yeah let's give a shout out really
appreciate it
people should really check out anna
chess on twitch
and on youtube can i be tricky
there's some greek gift ideas please let
me do it
i haven't sacrificed enough so far
oh they're letting me do it but is it
wait is it real is it a real gift or a
fake gift
i don't know i don't want to calculate
let's just do it and hope for the best
i can pre-move this i guess yeah because
if king h1 or king digs h2
it happens
oh thanks so much cd la tremont gifting
a sub
to mhs really appreciate that um yeah
again if you're just joining
this is an adoption match i have to win
10 in a row i've won
five so far the games have not been easy
and okay question is what to do probably
h5h4
looks enticing
yeah normally like there's some queen d6
to g6
it's also queen g5 as a resource
but this looks nice because h4 is kind
of hard to prevent
and the king can't run away knight's
always controlling each two
this move doesn't help because i still
play h4
actually really helps when i'm not
castled here
rook is clutch
there's a funny oh there's g5 made
potential
oh but it's not gonna happen i was gonna
i was gonna say
h4 and then g5 mates but so here just h4
is there a quicker way let's play h4
i'll win the queen
probably take on e3 and then when the
queen
here we go but how to break through
white has minor pieces
let's play this move
okay they're fighting on i can't let my
guard down
i want to play h3 i need g5
let's play g5 no mercy
i want to attack while i'm up material
now queen queen e5 i'm not an h3 coming
yeah forcing the h file to open i guess
there's g4 here
okay okay that was nice that was a that
was a fun
fun little yeah greek gift very typical
like opening middle game attack type
thing
so they're playing sicilian oh i could
play a wing gambit
oh does a does a wing gabbat work
this has has to be andrea playing the
openings
because i didn't think alexander plays
this
man what to play here
i could play let's play amora let's try
and get into amore again
because if they take then then it's
amura i'll just keep giving them the
option
please take my pawn i want to feel like
my
like mark esterman the mora god
ah they're not playing it but e6
e6 makes me happy
the dark squares are a bit weaker than
normal
can't really punish them yet
i guess e6 was intended to block the
bishop oh and play d5
i'll play bishop g5 i'm just going to
keep leaving the pawn
available for capturing
queen d2
i mean d oh d5 might be restricted yeah
let's play queen d2
also let's make anna chester vip thanks
nhs reading and
interacting in the chat really
appreciate it and then just
there we go okay oh d5 anyway
i thought this was covered but
the thing is i'm already down a pawn so
this is probably just trading
whoa it's another oh it's photo chess
thanks photo chess
man so many raids but i have to i this
is a critical moment
things are attacked but other things are
also attacked
someone give a shout out to photochests
um i think i'll take
i really don't want to lose a bishop
hair so let's be
let's be calm still
there's been tension so for so long here
between the pawns
yeah thanks so much maria lovalova
i'll i'll be i'll be streaming
commentary with photochest tomorrow
um appearing for
the st louis rapid and blitz coverage um
yeah it should be fun that will be
tomorrow
in like 19 hours from now
[Music]
yeah thanks again maria if you're just
joining if you're just joining i'm
playing a match against
the botest sisters um
having a lot of intense games let's take
the pawn
i i couldn't i couldn't deal with all
the tension there
um the the format of the match i need to
win 10 in a row to win the match
i've won six but i've had some close
calls
okay let's
actually don't know what the strategy is
here
this position might call for like
preventive play
like we both have isolated pawns
uh let's actually let's trade bishops
because this bishop is probably more
effective
we might see takes takes knight f5 and
then queen f4
okay oh the knight is fiend
let's defend the pawn even more
actually i probably should have the
rooks on e1 and c1
there's no reason to defend the pawn
whoa
thanks so much brother chess with a sub
appreciate that
love what oh something about love
oh love alerk oh
ah i missed i missed bishop a4
now if i play bishop a4 there's there's
b5 i can play knight a4
ah how am i i'm down 50 seconds okay
let's focus threatening this or this
dark squares are juicy i like the
the presence of the lightsweight bishops
too
queen d6 was a good move expecting b693
i'm dreaming of a world where i get this
and then this and then mate
even though that wouldn't be mate it
would be close
i mean there's always another f5 for
black
but okay 95 coming
probably combined with rook c1 some idea
to
penetrate the c6 square
we might see f6 or not
yeah let's um let's go after c6 most
likely rook c8
a good move i'll make luft for the king
now there's tension between the rooks
just stay focused some idea knight g4
[Music]
probably don't want to play that though
let's play rook c3
planning some kind of double up if takes
and i i control the c file
okay time is leveling leveling up that's
good so i was down on time
for a while there
bishop e4
i wonder if i can play my g4 here
actually let's ooh i'm playing knight g4
but then queen f4
it's kind of annoying probably g3
and then the bishop is strong
oh wait a minute i can trap the bishop
maybe f3 g4
it didn't even occur to me wow i had g4
probably earlier too
so bishop is low on squares
i have to watch out for this move oh
and they play it but i have this move oh
it's getting complicated
if takes i enter mesocheck and then take
back and then there's a pin
and i i would be up a piece there
okay here i'm winning everything
okay man
and these games take a lot of like
mental energy
all right seven wins let's go black
again
i think i know what to play this game oh
what is this
this is new opening discovery let's play
h5 maybe
whoa it's an enki due to reno
hot 500 bits thanks so much really
appreciate that
play d6 here maybe going for some
eventual kingside attack knight c6
an innovative panda slaving for eight
months
really appreciate that
okay we're having some weird closed
cecilia ooh let's talk a piece or let's
sack
the exchange yeah
i saw nerdski do this against john
bartholomew once it looked kind of cool
um i have to yeah i have to keep playing
aggressively
kind of scared of knight e5
but there's no time to be scared
my d5 could really be a annoying move
okay queen d2 is interesting bishop g5
ideas
also queenside castling ideas
let's develop
it's kind of backfiring
this may be really backfiring this queen
side attack is going to be slightly
scary
ah i could play king d7
i really should not have gone for this
i have rooks here maybe
honestly it might be the best approach
to play rook c8
because yeah white can't really get away
with taking i don't think
and i'll play rook or i'll play pawn
here
i've lost my my counseling privilege
privilege
unfortunately
but i still have d5 privileges
d5 could be really nice
let's do it
i might be inducing some bishop g5 move
oh but then i win a pong
okay takes takes
it's interesting like i'm down the
exchange but at least in the middle game
minor pieces can be more effective than
rooks
rooks can only come to life later on in
the end game
so all i have to do is avoid an endgame
which might be difficult but we'll see
and time is close to level
well i have this idea too knight c3
there's there's fork potential
i really have to be careful because
white has open lines
i'm just trying i'm not sure what to
expect here so i'm trying to just absorb
as many ideas as possible
and of course there's this idea there's
this idea too
but not here okay so let's take that
the bishop might move back and we repeat
i've opened one more file for whites but
i've won upon
okay so that move gives me a lot of
options
i could take the pawn twice and then get
mated
that's probably undesirable
guys queen c5 is kind of a cool move
there's some bishop h3 idea
this is a really confusing position
i'm trying to okay i have a little bit
of time
and there's so many options i know
bishop h3 is coming
i mean maybe d4
[Music]
actually there's a funny idea i'm gonna
play f6
provoking bishop e3 and then queen g3
[Music]
allowing rook g1 i think i'm
limiting the bishop but rook g1 can be
played but then i went upon
ooh i could win connect four
h5 is kind of scary have this move
oh rook h3 is a almost a queen it is a
queen trap
or no it's not queen g4
okay let's be careful
i have d d4 bishop g1
what is this position
let's play d4 let's kind of relieve some
tension
if rook h3 here i oh i just take it oh
okay i won connect four everything
should be okay i have a nice
juicy e3 square and bishop
before ideas of 86 ideas i'm down on
time
[Music]
i mean it's really up to white to figure
out what to do here
it seems like some nice domination i
think this white is still up material
so i don't want to trade much
okay let's put the queen on g4
pressure against the rook it's actually
really hard to
find a productive plan here for white oh
force played
it's probably a good move
let's take once
it takes some bishop before
i can't be moving this slowly
e4 is a really good move let's play
bishop b4 first
knight c3 maybe 94.
i'm looking for tactics where i win back
material but it's not so simple
[Music]
maybe rook d8
and just throw the ball to white
i'm threatening some bishop c4
i mean there's no bishop e2 the rook is
restricted queen side down to the bishop
and finally i'm up on time
that's a nice sign
i forgot about the each pawn okay let's
take that
i might see a trade
rose in 2020. hey that's me and that's
this year
thanks so much chassis spaghett welcome
back
okay i have to stay focused
and h files open i have to be very aware
of rook h8 ideas
but i have a nice center nice central
knights
i'm just waiting for a3 so i can fork
and think you pick your poison i was
saving my twitch prime to use on your
stream that i accidentally let my paint
sub
automatically renew
i mean yeah show some love oh it's a
fork
yeah my opponent needs
some uh some healing in the form of a
prime sub
maybe c6 it's a tricky move
i could also maybe i'll just take the
rook
and queen a4 c6 takes i when the bishop
ah what to do let's play this move
oh my time wait okay
i know they're fast too to be very very
careful here
i just want to play solid moves and
quick moves
finding this maybe oh no my queen
don't hurt me oh let's
save this first
nice tactic
dirty [ __ ]
that was man i got comfortable and then
i got low on time and i lost my queen
oh man
i can only imagine how
[Music]
bad they feel right now i don't know
whether to feel good or bad about that
thankfully that's what purell is for
not sponsored but kills 99.9
percent of the germs ah
i feel very dirty after that one
okay but yeah the final position is just
a
dead draw obstacle color bishop ending
i would have been bummed if you d i d n
t dirty flag them at least once
uh so that means you're not bummed
anymore right
i don't wanna bum anyone
okay
eight eight games i just have to take it
one game at a time
really one move at a time man
okay
stay calm after meditate to focus on the
breath
okay yeah they're probably gonna need to
recover after that one
what color was i i was black so i'll be
white next game okay let's um
i'll play d4 again let's play like a
tricky london line maybe
tricky london let's go oh let's play um
the stuff yeah like um
trying to think if there's any gambits i
can play
really depends what black plays
um i could use the same ideas
as earlier i'll start with queen d2
um but i'll probably at some point like
push
each five they're they're already
stopping my h-pawn advance
they know my plans okay let's castle
queenside
um i still want to like play in some
kind of gambit style
um but how do i gambit
wisely let's play f3 always play f3
oh always play king b12 i have to make
ben feingold proud
yeah okay i got my
got my basic structure at some point at
some point i'll sack something
maybe e5 e5 is not really a sack but
it's a trade
maybe g4
oh knight c6
hmm i was about to blunder the pawn on
d4
i'm actually wondering if i can get away
with that
let's do it that looks like a fun gambit
actually
so i'm losing a pawn but then i play e5
and then after takes takes
i'm still down the pawn but i'll have
some initiative
there's some traps where i take on b5
and then checkmate on d8
like all i need to do is remove this
this and this and then checkmate
oh they don't take the bait
castling so the pawn is still hanging i
should probably
not lose it
i could move it i could play d5
or i could just ignore it yeah let's
play bishop here i'm just going to leave
it hanging
black is free to take it i just want to
meet i want to get the queen in
get the knight in remove this knight
and play queen h7
um so they're really against taking the
pawn e5 is probably a
nice thematic move
okay i'll play d5 winning connect four
i don't know how thrilled i am about
this position
i'm gonna leave the tension between the
bishops
maybe go for g4 at some point
good take when in doubt on passant
and how i cracked this position
h4 and then later g4 and if takes i
have some h5 ideas am i scared about
that
and this pawn is a little bit of a
target
um let's get really sharp really quickly
i want to play knight g5
okay let's take and then play knight g5
and then play g4
and then try and break through
hey thanks for subbing avery high
training and be a daddy i believe
we'll see you can't
count your wait
i want to say can't count your eggs
but you can't count your children before
they
i don't know okay let's let's not get
distracted let's uh let's focus
uh let's not get made it
i think i can take this yeah then bishop
c4
both pawns are hanging and the king is
actually really safe here
bishop defends a2 like the main
attacking idea for black is a5 a4 b3
which is a little bit slow i still have
g4 ideas
oh there's a cool line oh oh this is a
cool line too
who's this move
it's actually a cool move as it takes
there's rook t8s
okay so i can take once or i can just
leave the tension
i'm kind of inclined to take once i'll
let them enjoy their center and then
move here
if i took it again there's rook d8 and
there'd be
some annoying pin
okay now i'm thinking this move takes
and then this move and then takes and
then takes and then takes and then this
and then this and then mate let's do it
i'll just pre-move this
and my time i'm living in like some
fantasy variations where
forgetting about my time deficit
but okay the pressure's on black
if they don't take i probably play rook
dg1
maybe queen it's a nice little pocket
a sandwich between the pawns like queen
g5 and then like g3 to f5
let's start with that
because now the knight is kind of pinned
to the other knight it's hard to remove
the queen
i'm actually threatening to take because
both things are pinned
oh okay i think i can still take
there's takes and then knight f4
probably
neither four could be really nice yeah
threatening the triple fork
the thing is when you threaten the
triple fork if they move any one of
these pieces
it's still a double fork oh also this is
a
this is a threat too yeah the like
everything's working well here for white
like the bishop the king is very safe
oh it's a quad oh did they play that
just for the the beauty
look at this oh it's so beautiful it's a
royal
fork of goodness oh i should
take this and frame it on my wall
oh it's so nice i should turn this into
like a t-shirt
knife f4 for the four yeah more like
knife e6
knife f4 was just a pre-fork
but yeah knives can also be forks
or sporks i don't know whoa
okay that's nine down
let's not choke one more
okay
one more oh i'm gonna be black if they
play d4 i play c5
this is going to be a fun fun little
gamut opening
okay i used to play this i actually used
to play this in over-the-board chess
this is a benoni dutch oh thank you
orion arrow
um i got my last i am norm playing this
variation
in the tournament it was beautiful
so the okay it's not really gambit but
it's just a fun line
idea to do benoni things
and dutch things so the general setup is
to get two pawn chains and then
see what white does oh
i'll try not to have to eat
properly and slowly oh h4 h4 is actually
kind of a scary move
but is it so scary i might as well play
d6
i mean they might they might end up like
sacking
they might be inspired by my previous
sacrifices
queen d2 was actually a little bit
unsettling
i think i'll play h6 here if i were to
castle there'd be really scariness
yeah bishop there that's a solid move
let's play knight a6
okay really can't let my guard down it's
a weird
kind of form of development play bishop
d7
so i'm allowing this but i'd be okay
with that i have the b
file in the meantime i might want to
play b5 like b5 b4
use the diagonal or chase the knight
away from
controlling e4 so it's actually a rich
position
yeah i can play like b4 here
so a4 was played to discourage b5 but
maybe b5 can still be achieved
not sure though i want to play e6 but
then a5
i could play b6
um let's start with this
expecting a5 and maybe knight g4
it's a strange position a5 okay
so i'm unleashing the bishop
my knights are on exotic squares
almost exotic or almost as exotic as joe
exotic
okay i could castle actually
yeah why not castling i forgot this
battery doesn't even exist and the pawns
defended twice
and this this bishop's not too
terrifying as long as there's a pawn
here
oh e4 is an idea e4 is actually a really
strong idea
but probably not or maybe it is playable
i'll play queen e8
i do queen f7 i just want to be prepared
for that file opening
just realized e5 could happen
this is actually kind of scary and they
open the battery too
man
okay let's take so white's getting an e
file i get the f file
it's a very tense position there's a lot
happening
i mean all the minor pieces on the board
things are kind of undefended like b
pawn is hanging i don't think i want to
take it
time is level some bishop f5 idea
also i should note that white was
threatening this
with the dirty pin
okay let's go for this some nice bishops
sure the piece harmony is actually quite
nice here like the pieces make
sense they don't really get in the way
of each other
is my night just hanging uh oh
oh no my knight's not or is it i have
this move
okay thankfully i have this move i
didn't see that
but if takes i win the bishop i lose a
pawn but
i think everything's okay that was a
close call
i was really lucky i'm thankful that
bishop's not defended
oh thank you moss jaw moss jaw
it's something with prime thanks so much
okay that's a wake-up call like c3 i
really have to
be careful of danger
i imagine they didn't see this move
coming
it's just an unexpected resource if i
have the chance i might play 95
i might undevelop and then set up for
the
the next game oh but there's not going
to be a next game what does this move
my take takes oh
wait oh this that could be a really
strong move
wow what a move
that's a really strong move i can play
rook d-a maybe
no i can oh i can take but then ticks
takes ticks man
and the thing's defending
um
wow i could take on a5 maybe
i think i should take on e5 and just try
and survive
maybe
because i'm attacking the bishop if
takes takes takes queen d7
takes rook takes d6 okay we're gonna go
into it
i'm gonna be down the pawn
but maybe it's okay
so takes queen d7 takes
takes d6 king h7
oh white why could win c5 too
i might have to resort to dirty flagging
and they're playing a really good game
wait what free knight
oh there's a g6 rookie seven of the
mountain king
um
i have to stay focused wow look at this
move
it might not be good but it's confusing
finally made it for a stream
oh welcome
i have to take it this is really scary
because d6 and
oh bishop d5 too
live queen b6 attacking the rook
this is so terrifying
really don't know what to make of this
queen b6
let's play queen b6
okay seven is my hope as there's also
targeting target on f2
okay
[Music]
time is very relevant as well
[Music]
so g7 is vulnerable but i think it's
defended i just want to win a pawn
and i want to mate two just want two
things in life
but f2 so the queen can move somewhere
actually
but can it move so i can take
wow
what's going on here
i don't see my meat
[Music]
i'm not seeing it
[Music]
i didn't see it watch out for queen g8s
[Music]
yo my bishop
wait oh it's a draw oh no are they true
i thirty five of them but it didn't
matter
oh what a finish
[Music]
i don't know whether to be happy about
the dirty flag or sad that
it's a draw because insufficient mating
material even though fide would declare
this a win
i think
it's uh what is it i don't know it's
yeah i i didn't wow they played so well
that game
they played so well
are they are they celebrating they're
probably celebrating
wow what a game
that was crazy oh a few days
yeah yeah it would count as a win
according to fiji but
wow gg's that was
man that was heart-wrenching
i think they they found some really good
moves
like look at these moves
like this whole idea of taking on g6 i
mean it was just a whole mess
i wonder who found this alexandra or
andrea or both
oh i'm still on their stream i loaded up
their stream
so we can see we can see here
wow it's it's inception
wow can i do this can i do this wow look
at them
good job
[Music]
that was yeah i hope people enjoy that i
hope people enjoy that
um this will probably go on youtube this
will go on their youtube channel too
people can watch from both perspectives
oh she's calling oh join join call
hello hey eric thanks so much for the
match you played so well
you guys did too yeah that was i mean
that was really heart-wrenching towards
the end
uh your last game was amazing like you
guys found some really nice resources
there
it's funny we actually mouse slipped
queen d5 but then it ended up being okay
queen d5 on move 28.
i've been waiting no queen d5 is such a
good move
because it's tricky at least like i take
on f2 and then i can't
i can't mate because you're defending
everything and then you always have
queen g8 ideas
perpetual at least which was nice yeah
yeah i know
it's like it's so scary like with g7
under pressure
yeah i really wanted to sack my queen
take on g2
and then play knight e3 where did you
want to stay on on g2
oh right after queen takes up two after
queen f2 king h1 queen takes g2
but your rook is covering e3 so i can't
i can't simplify
oh so i was like crazy it was like crazy
it wasn't intense last game
yeah did so who who found
which one of you found taking on d6
because that was a really impressive
move
i think it was moved oh
did it i did did i find it or wait no it
was move 19. the ship takes g6 was a
really cool resource
no i don't think so no yeah i found
bishop taking six
but anyway andrea this was the one where
we kept calculating like what happened
yeah but andrea helped me think no i'll
explain this one on our own uh
i'm sure it was some some level of
teamwork yeah exactly no
the teamwork was helpful our first two
games were good and then we started
slipping off and then at least we saved
it in the end
i was really scared i was gonna just
lose the first game and that would be
the match
yeah your your funky openings definitely
gave us a big advantage
yeah i was trying to be as tricky as
possible but some some gambits you
weren't accepting so it's frustrating
but
i tried to make the most of it yeah did
you like when we sacked on f2
in that one game and got a crit yeah i
like it it probably isn't a good move
but somehow it became easier for you to
play
yeah it threw me off because i wanted to
be the one like down material and
playing aggressively and then i had to
play defensively
yeah i know you're really scary when
you're playing aggressively yeah
oh thank you that one game where we got
also nice
fork when you put all our pieces all are
rocks and queen
i'm used to like just playing dubious
gambit so
usually i'm i'm forced to play
aggressively otherwise
things don't go so well so it's it's a
fun style for blitz because it's more
fun just to attack
and faster games yeah no that's for sure
but are you gonna keep yeah it does we
we should do this again at some point
yeah yeah definitely um yeah this was a
very nice map
i enjoyed it i hope i hope the fans
enjoyed it too i i think it attracted
some
some nice viewership so i i hope so are
you going to keep streaming by the way
uh probably not i was going to ask you
the same thing because i'd be happy to
to send a radio yeah i think we were
about to head off so we're going to uh
okay whatever yeah maybe we can go our
separate ways because uh
yeah i've had a long day so i knew i
especially need to recover
so this is this is where we might thank
you for the game
thank you eric yeah very good games
thanks alexandra thanks andrea
um have have a good night and yeah we'll
be in touch for
you another one take care all right bye
eric
all right bye